Good morning John, and happy Pizzamas.
As I think you expected, people have been
enjoying your green-screen time.
They're calling it John Greenscreened; it's
a thing, it's beautiful.
But I want to skip back another video, to
the almost incalculably distant Friday video
that I did, in which I used the word "dipthong".
Which, unfortunately, does not exist.
The word I was going for was diphthong, which
is also really great.
I have pronounced and spelled diphthong wrong
for at least a decade.
I am not embarrassed about my misunderstanding
with the diphthong word, and I want to know
why!
In college, I did an oral presentation on
Leon Battista Alberti, who was a mathematician,
architect, and artist of the Renaissance.
Super cool dude, if you ever want to learn
about him.
He designed a great number of the fronts of
buildings in Florence.
Those fronts of buildings are called that
word (façade), which I said, for the entire
presentation, "fah-caid".
Like, 26 times, I said "fah-caid", and I knew
something wasn't going well, but I just powered
through, you know, and then found out later,
from a friend, "fuh-SAHD".
Anhhhhhhh . . .
So I mispronounced Diphthong in front of 200,000
people - didn't bother me.
"Fah-caid", in front of twenty people, left
a permanent scar.
Like, I still have a hard time telling that
story.
What is the difference between those two things?
I think it's mostly confidence.
Like, being confident when you're wrong is
one of the most amazing things you can be.
It's wonderful... if you can pull it off,
which is impossible.
I don't mean confidence in believing a thing
that is wrong and continuing to believe a
thing despite knowing that it's wrong, which
some people are really into.
I mean, finding out you're wrong, knowing
you're wrong, and being confident in your
understanding of your own wrongness.
When you see someone be super-wrong and be
like, "Eh, whatever, yeah, I was wrong.
Yeah!
Thanks for letting me know!"
you're like "That person is cool.
They're cool.
How do I get that?"
Feeling fine about being wrong is the logical
way to feel, because, as I have pointed out
in previous videos, I am a towering mountain
of ignorance, and all simplicity is a lie.
Even when you're right, you're a little bit
wrong!
Getting to a place where I feel comfortable
enough with myself to have internalized that
truth, even a little bit, has been a lifelong
process.
And really, it only works when I'm in places
and with people who I trust and know and understand
and feel good about and feel confident around,
which is the case here - the Vlogbrothers
channel and nerdfighteria.
Embarrassment really isn't about being wrong,
it's about feeling wrong, and it is hard for
me to feel wrong here, because you guys are
nice.
Sometimes the most embarrassing part of the
embarrassment is the embarrassment itself!
That's weird!
In the comments on my Friday video, I owned
up, and I said that I mispronounced "dipthong,"
just like John recently mispronounced "hectacre,"
and I asked people to tell me their hectacre
moments.
And I read through them, just before I made
this video, and it was wonderful.
There's like 300 replies and they're all hilarious
and wince-inducing.
But several of them were also façade, which
made me feel better about myself, and I think
in general, that thread was cathartic for
all the people who participated in it.
Being wrong is part of what it is to be a
person.
And you have to work on how to be wrong without
feeling wrong.
I think that thread was a good start.
So I'm going to ask all of you: if you got
a little time, tell us an embarrassing thing
that has happened to you.
We can read it and feel better about ourselves,
knowing that everyone does dumb things!
But I think owning it is the number one thing
you can do, and I think the other thing you
can do is let people know who are admitting
to their embarrassing things that have happened
to them, that they're awesome, and that that's
hilarious, and not to worry about it.
That's hopefully what's going on in the comments;
John, I'll see you tomorrow.
Hi, endscreen!
This is sad - only three days left of Pizzamas,
but the Project for Awesome is coming up,
so there are reasons to celebrate the future.
Because of Paper Towns shoot dates, we're
actually moving the Project for Awesome up
this year, it's going to be the 12th and 13th
of December.
So mark your calendars and start planning
your videos.